now 34 million school hours are lost
each year due to emergency visits to the
dentist office 8 News now's Brian
right to the schools
those are your ceilings the Dentistry we
can prevent a significant amount of
disease simply by placing a sealant
which will protect a healthy tooth or we
can give fluoride which will also help
strengthen the teeth a healthy body
begins with a healthy smile but for many
of these students they don't have the
ability to get dental care we're 100
free and reduced lunch 100 title Title
One those students don't have access
that's where Terry Chandler comes in
with future Smiles a non-profit that
goes into 50 schools in Clark County
serving 5 000 children grew up in Las
Vegas I'm a dental hygienist I practice
in Las Vegas since
1999. so it was important to me to give
back to this community and I found an
opportunity by providing school-based
Dental Health Services this team of
future Smiles behind me is delivering
Smiles on the go to these Local
Elementary School students
my favorite part was getting my was
getting my teeth all nice shiny and
clean the students received a dental
health screening got their teeth cleaned
and sealants to protect against cavities
getting to Children early before they
have a cavity is what's pivotal it's
vital yeah to have people support not
only your school but the members of the
community